that room oh hey hello everybody my name
is markiplier welcome back to blank
dream okay so I got the silver key which
means obviously if I wasn't big dumb
dumb that I can go in the silver door I
don't remember those another civil door
that I think this is it
okay good what realm is this anyway
realm of spirits Oh tragedies end oh no
oh no a shoe rack but not a single shoe
so secret to be had here might be okay
not a single shoe not a single shoe shoe
okay I just had to be certain I had no
idea oh this looks so comforting oh I
can't wait to get eaten alive by all the
spirits here the seventh mystery one who
personally witnesses mysteries one to
six will be led to the locked away
mirror so I have to witness all the
other mysteries what you're saying the
second mystery the portrait in the
reception room will attack students who
sneaked in to cause trouble great oh
good so a portraits gonna be angry at me
I mean it's not like I did any portrait
any wrong around here hello who are you
the six mystery is the Forgotten
classroom there's a room with an
entrance that can't be seen I heard it
somewhere around the bathrooms but I'm
not interested enough to look myself
okay thank you
have you seen a statue walking in the
halls the first mystery is called the
moving sex no have not and I would
rather not do that when you've seen the
statue itself but no one's ever seen him
moving man if I found it I'd give it a
good kick why why would you do that that
seems like the exact opposite of what
you want to do two moving statues you
either flirt with them or you run away
at full speed no the piano in contrast
to the dusty room there's a stain on it
okay a portrait of a familiar person he
says nothing staring into space Porcha
TIF a familiar person portrait of a
familiar person third mystery there's if
there's sheet music on the music piano
rooms piano it'll start playing by
itself I'm out of here okay okay that
room oh hey what the [ __ ] uh uh okay
Jesus god damn it
ah god damn that was not okay
holy [ __ ] I was not ready for that god
damn I was just trying to take a
breather oh god damn it
I don't like you I don't like none of
you goddamn oh [ __ ] you
okay hello forth mr. yzma cheap Michiko
of the toilet do you know of it in the
girls bathroom if you knock three times
on the far left door and say Michiko
Michiko to come out I'm not gonna try it
though right for the best god damn
you've seen zero of the seven mysteries
myths are these illusions or embodiments
of the attachment not okay
fourth mystery there's a single cursed
shoe rack in the entryway I looked I
thought I looked oh hi bronze statue of
an old man hammer deco night experience
the first mystery good I'll see now not
what I expected but okay all righty then
yeah you two go would you do do do do do
do do okay so it's random chance if they
appear in the hallway
all right Michiko Michiko a sink is
stained with red liquid mmm is that
painting blood I have no idea that's
doing red paint hmm far left or not
three times Michiko about Jake ow
Michelle open the door but no no it
didn't
maybe it's not wise to approach yeah
I'll come back for that god I saw that
brother you call balls it's all a death
trap it's all a goddamn death trap it's
all Frank lack and death trap that's
what this is oh man not okay not okay if
I knew I was just gonna die then I would
have been crap I didn't do that right
try that again
let's see you got Michiko hi how's it
going
all right let's see what you got
actually no I am gonna get saved first
OOP he's in here ah Oh God why god damn
it I can't Ren God son of a [ __ ] just
let me win just let me frickin frackin
Flakoll a can win oh man I just want to
win okay come on cloud bug jjigae but
you go I know I know I know I know
I know I know I know okay thank you
thank you thank you thank you okay come
on come on come on I got to get around
this guy
what no no no no no no no no oh where am
I oh I'm in oh that's right there was a
thing in the bath the scattered sack of
a taker
okay got a sheet music hmm least I got
around the ghost to you Ruki but now I
can go back and experience the mystery
of the bathroom release the death three
there's nothing there
oh okay yeah sure sure there ain't all
I've been in I've not been in this one I
don't think
okay got it
oh I guess I can go back and experience
the mystery of the shoe rack that's
something I need to do so I checked all
of these pretty sure anyway they might
need to check the backs of them okay so
the next thing I need to do is I need to
put the sheet music on here but the
sheet music boo Boop okay got it
yay good beautiful
experience the third mystery okay good
painting gonna just gonna go save I'm
gonna go save
nope ain't gonna save now I'm safe later
okey good yes
all right so now I need to go find out
what's not that one I need to go find
out what's in here cuz there's something
in here oh oh is this the room oh I
think this might be the room some kind
of certificate hello okay how are you
nobody safe for you okay alright okay
we're okay okay okay god damn it god
damn it I don't like none of this none
of this is okay it's exactly none okay
not okay none of it's okay okay alright
five of the seven mysteries miss loosens
are embodiments of attachment I don't
remember which one I haven't seen
alright what about out here you okay
nope nope nope nope nope ain't no how
about no okay okay uh there's a single
cursed shoe rack in the entryway I
that's got to be like it's got to be one
of them but I don't know I've looked at
all of them no no I couldn't of course I
couldn't I would just be obscene well
here's the mysterious room I don't think
there was anything in here squeeze
squeeze squeeze she ok so there's gotta
be it's gotta be something to that I
mean I looked at every single one of
them
wait I thought I heard something
Oh Oh
okay so I had to look individually at oh
okay Speirs v memory good good okay good
I think that's all that I needed right I
think so anyway
I'm pretty sure I did I I think like the
okay damn it that guy does not go away
okay thank you all right so with that
being said I'm pretty sure that's all
the mysteries I could encounter correct
correct six is seven mysteries are these
illusions our bodies the seventh mystery
was experiencing all the mysteries right
for sure oh that's okay that's just a
shortcut to where I need to go all right
seventh mystery wanted personally
witnesses one mysteries one two six will
be led to the aah here we go okay gotta
gotta gotta got it okay so now I'm at
the mirror not where I need to be
looking looking yes look in look deep
into the mirror sorry I'm just a little
jittery six years ago in elementary
school just generic any elementary
school do okay where am I Who am I Sooey
aren't you coming we're going to explore
the ghost lake you're such a fat
follower catch hand
it's just a rumor okay same as the
school seven mysteries oh that's not
true they found a body there last year
remember and last week they found
another which means the demon of the
ghost Lake is making people throw
themselves in that's just a coincidence
it's a pretty deep lake so everyone just
picks it to off themselves no that's not
it they say the body they found last
week died exactly one year after the one
from last year which means that one year
later at the same time the same place
somebody's gonna die again and both
victims were students from the same ni
let's go for real it was on the news you
can't call that a coincidence yeah it is
a little strange of someone from the
exact same school would die exactly a
year later the girls lake wants
sacrifices there's got to be an evil
ghost using black
magic we should exterminate it yeah us
kids can handle it all right I guess
it's worth checking out feels more like
a plot than a ghost but it'll do
alright Tarot hiko then let's get going
wait wasn't six years ago when that
guy's sister drowned okay no boys are
into that kind of thing huh
it's kind of scary to think people are
dying in the same day each year I don't
want to get into anything weird and if
it's just kids going our parents will
get mad Cu Mashiro
you should go home quick and not get
involved with that stuff wait Oh
am I playing mashiro Tsui wasn't that
the name of the sister maybe not sure Oh
where'd my pen go maybe I lost it when
we played hide-and-seek hmm some library
books mixed in but nothing out of the
ordinary I'm looking for a pen for my
friend library books mixing it won't
open okay out of the locker Lots brooms
not much else still people in the
classroom Oh from jumping out the window
okay I gotcha how did the teacher's desk
ballpoint pen got it okay all righty
then
hello Oh my pen I did there for
hide-and-seek
Thanks finding it I'm gonna go home see
you tomorrow okay
all right well duh now's a good time as
any oh god that's so morbid oh man oh
man so morbid
Oh God oh hi thank you okay good
glad oh this game is just so dark it's
good though it's it's good but it's dark
uh so she felt the strong pain and her
vision blurring there wasn't even a
bruise on her yes there were rumors
about the ghost Lake back then that was
probably where the mirror lake rumor
started but ultimately after the second
death there were no more incidents
involving Mirror Lake Elementary School
I seem to recall that was a pretty fun
time god she lost something important
again good great got a gold key okay all
right oh man is so much fun so that's
all the time I got for this up is gear
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you're enjoying it so far man it
was like this particular episode got me
more than any other episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other scare games that I've played
in the description down below huge
playlist lots game other RPG horror
Maker games and as always I will see you
in the next video
dangerous concern any metal especially
if you haven't have weapon